today the underpriced attention is
1998 Wine Library my dad's liquor store
had 150 000 people on its email
newsletter and had 91.3 open rates
Google AdWords when they came out I
bought every wine term people forget but
they were five cents floor for about
eight months or so before 10 cents
became the floor and literally I owned
every word from wine itself to Silver
Oak to Chateau lafe and I was able to
build a very large business for my dad
with very little Capital because I was
able to understand where the underpriced
attention was and I was able to
understand how to fill that underpriced
attention with the creative
yeah
great to have you here Gary it is uh
truly an honor for me personally I don't
know if you remember I think we brought
it up for probably not in a long time
about 15 years ago when you had my
library and my brother and I we're
starting our alcohol brand Thief not to
be confused with v but we could have
could have been Partners maybe back then
uh we reached out to you and and so uh
it's an honor to share a stage with you
and come a long way since a couple adult
beverage guys congrats on everything
thank you it's really nice to be with
everybody
um you know for the last panel but one
of the things that I I really have
always respected a ton about you is is
the kind of the grit and the hustle and
it doesn't have to be burned out but for
the last panel it was really interesting
I kind of think that those are some of
the quality qualities
um that I think you know you're really
embody so anyways moving to the Future
what what are kind of Industries or
areas that you think are really going to
be disrupted in in the next five years
like what what will surprise us or what
do you think no one kind of sees coming
right now
you know it's ironic given you know the
makeup of the room in here I actually
think which is unusual by standards of
the last two decades I think almost no
one here is going to be surprised about
the disruption in the next five years
because I think the aggressiveness of
how big the technology and movement of
AI is would I'd be shocked if people
here would be surprised that literally
everything is in play to be disrupted
given the nature of how large this
Innovation is I think this moment that I
think we're in is a little bit more
similar to the late 90s early 2000s when
it was obvious if you were paying paying
attention or in a room like this with
the kind of people that are in this room
that this internet thing was really
going to disrupt everything I think the
question becomes timing when I hear the
five-year question it's not what's going
to be disrupted the answer is everything
it's in what pattern right bookstores
were just really unlucky first and and
then people that owned medallions on
cabs 15 20 years later so I think for a
lot of us in this room it's an
interesting time to navigate our
decisions and our opportunity costs and
our investments and what we want to get
into because
there is just a lot going on not not
only the acceleration of Technologies
we've been waiting for or aware of
there's many people here I remember four
or five years ago looking at a lot of AI
companies and even with my slightly
solid somewhat dangerous understanding
of technology I realized half of them
were really just apis being put together
and were Bozo or maybe on a good day
some ml stuff but not really there and
then here we are and this is the year
where you're really seeing stuff you're
like this is what we were talking about
six seven years ago so I think you know
I think that I think look just things I
think everyone should be thinking about
here I I was born in the former Soviet
Union what there's a lot to that but I
think one of the things that it reminds
me of is like people in the 50s 60s and
70s around the world didn't go to all
the places around the world like if
you're An American in 1972 like you
weren't going to Yugoslavia like you
weren't going like you weren't and I
think we have a major rise of
nationalism and geopolitics and bricks
and the US dollar and this and so I
think another thing that will become
more clear over the next five years is
like the world's changing in front of us
and that's going to impact the way we
make investing decisions and life
decisions so I guess to answer your
question I think everything is in play
and that makes it harder or more
exciting depending on where everyone
here is in their cycle
well on that note as a as a master of
the medium
um how do you kind of see social media
evolving in the next decade
you know it's funny you know I I'm not
really that obsessed or or overly
emotional about the concept of social
media in the way that I think maybe some
would think if they've even spent the
second paying attention to what I'm up
to I'm I'm obsessed and focused on the
concept of where attention is
you know so if I started my marketing
firm in the late 90s we would have been
in email marketing Google AdWords
company right you know it's actually
really fun visually I'm seeing two of
the more handsome men in the room Tim
Armstrong and Ben Lear one was very
prolific in email and one was very
prolific in Google ads and that would
have been my firm in 2000 because I knew
that was underpriced attention for some
of the ogs in this room in 1998 Wine
Library my dad's liquor store had 150
000 people on its email newsletter and
had 91.3 open rates
when Ben started to realist there was no
chance he could achieve that because the
medium of consumer Behavior had shifted
and marketers like myself had ruined
email for other people and they could
never achieve those numbers Google
AdWords when they came out I bought
every wine term people forget but they
were five cents floor for about eight
months or so before 10 cents became the
Florin literally I owned every word from
wine itself to Silver Oak to Chateau
lafe and I was able to build a very
large business for my dad with very
little Capital because I was able to
understand where the underpriced
attention was and I was able to
understand how to fill that underpriced
attention with the creative whether that
was the copywriting back then today the
underpriced attention is Facebook reels
right this second as we sit here right
this second
scaled underpriced attention to Market
in America and many parts of the world
sits on Facebook reels
the amount of people talking about
Facebook reels is like seven
and so just to clarify when you say the
Facebook reels you mean Instagram reels
I sure don't just clarify it
um
I sent the company-wide email the other
day which I rarely do but I'm like I
need everybody to get focused on
Facebook reels immediately literally
half my company emailed me back they're
like I don't even have Facebook because
I have so many people under 26 and I was
literally it was quite enjoyable to
reply back to them like you know how
you've been [__] on everyone for not
knowing Tick Tock well now they're gonna
[__] on you
and so you know I think for me what do I
think about the next 10 years I think
it'd be stunning if we didn't have a
decentralized social network at scale in
10 years I think that's a elephant in
the room that would be really
interesting to see I think you know I
think with AI and deep fake and all the
stuff that we're about to deal with I
think decentralized servers web 3 is
about to really start showing people its
value improving Providence I think we're
all very aware of people's cynicism and
politics that come along with
centralized social networks so even with
blue sky and what jacks up to like I
think it'd be shocking if in 10 years we
don't have a decentralized social
network that's successful I'd be
surprised if two or three more snap or
tick tocks didn't come along I think I
view social networks kind of like I view
very successful TV shows like
Seinfeld or you know SNL which is having
a long run like they're going to be
platforms that come out that have 7 10
12 year runs but then like nightlife
like a club or a restaurant can only
stay so hot for so long because the next
Generation kind of wants their own place
so I think when I when I hear that
question I think over the next five to
ten years you'll see another emerge
because gen Alpha is gonna need their
spot and they're going to make fun of
tick tock the way the tick tock
generation made fun of Instagram the way
the Instagram generation made fun of
Facebook so I think there'll be two to
three other places and in the first 24
to 48 months of that platform there'll
be an enormous opportunity for every
person in this room regardless of what
they want to achieve at that point
people here may want to run for office
raise capital for a non-profit start a
new business build a personal brand
whatever it may be in that 24 to 48
months there'll be an opportunity to
outflank and I think what continues to
happen in my professional life The
Fortune 500 advertising landscape is the
biggest brands in the world that spend
the most money are incredibly slow
because they run on fake reports
and so they don't know how to justify
the ROI of new platforms that will
continue to be the Arbitrage until that
world changes and I don't see that
changing very quickly and so that's
where a lot of opportunity for all of us
continues to be and so those are some of
the nuances I expect yeah
um this is what your I think you answer
my next two questions already I was
going to ask where the market dollars
will go you gave us the Facebook reels
tip
um and I was going to ask but maybe but
there's a lot of them to just add more
value to the art like spotify's
biddable product where you can just
literally record on your memos a radio
ad and place it on spotify's free
product is a crazy underpriced attention
execution at scale influencers can be a
crazy place where you waste money but it
can be the greatest place to buy
underpriced even traditional mediums
outdoor Billboards when you don't buy
them on contract you buy them Remnant
when they're available for two months in
between two contracts for a remarkable
Arbitrage on getting attention for what
you want versus what you pay for so you
know I think the more this room can
think about day trading attention that
this is not a set it and forget it this
is not a it's the way it is it's a
constant moving variable I think that
can service people well because at the
end of the day regardless of what anyone
is doing in this room the one thing I'm
sure of that connects everyone is you're
trying to find mediums to let people
know about it so they do the thing you
want them to do whether you throw a
conference whether make videos like the
punch line of everything is nothing that
anyone here wants to accomplish is
achievable without other people knowing
about it and acting on it
and so to me what was clear 15 years ago
was technology was going to commoditize
a whole lot of things except the ability
to be a contemporary communicator and
that whomever was best at being a
contemporary Communicator at scale would
have a lot of Leverage and that's why
I've been eating [__] for 13 years
building an agency because it's really
just a front for what I'm up to which is
world domination
I don't even know how we build on that
but I have lots of thoughts on how
they're the things that you can't
replicate over there some of the things
you're talking about contemporary
communication real relationships but
um you've given us some really
interesting things to focus on
I'm gonna try and trick you up here what
is something worth not investing in kind
of coming up in the next cycle or two
whether it's whether it's an actual
monetary investment or more an
investment of time well I think the
thing I'm talking about is being great
at communicating today
I think what's very obvious in my
corporate world is that people are
obsessed with yesterday
they still want to do a television ad as
if anyone on Earth watches them and by
the way just to give me context 80
billion dollars worth of media being
bought for television network and cable
ads let alone the money that's being
spent on making the ads
I think the place this kind of room gets
kicked up on is why last year in the
hype of nfts and the things that were
happening the place where I was trying
to stop a lot of friends were going to
was the metaverse because the humans
weren't there
this room this energy this DNA doesn't
get caught up on believing in yesterday
it is believing in tomorrow too soon
so the place not worry the place not to
invest in is we are aware that these
Technologies are in place but pay
attention to what the consumer is
actually doing versus a what you'd like
them to do because you wrote a check
which is just a killer and I appreciate
the reaction from several of you the
place that is just so obvious to me is
like you wrote a check and now you want
it to be true
it's much better to be thoughtful before
you write the check if it is true and I
think when you list the things that I've
invested in I became a worse investor
over time in the beginning when I was
writing checks all I was doing was based
on like oh this is happening now and
like people don't see it and then over
time you make a bunch of good
Investments you get fancy and you think
you're good at something and and I had
to recalibrate back and now I try to if
I'm writing a check it's like it's
actually happening not it might happen
it could happen and so you know people
are going to get caught on VR being too
early people are going to get caught on
a lot of things the other thing is
people get caught up in headlines and
they're not actually educated in the
craft I am uncomfortably bullish on I
think of AI Like Oxygen it's done it's a
foregone conclusion and I'm putting in a
ton of work to understand it but I've
been very patient in writing checks
because it's no different than when I
was bullish on social networks when I
saw the Myspace thing I don't know if a
lot of you I mean looking at the crowd
and knowing some faces here you'll
remember it wasn't Myspace in Facebook
it was Myspace Facebook orchid
in Brazil Tim
um you know it was high five it was tag
world we had we had Niche social
networks everybody remember dogster we
needed a Social Network for our dogs
like you know and so what's gonna happen
right now is over the next 24 months the
enormous amount of checks and money and
time and energy people are going to put
into AI companies where the decision
maker
a doesn't even understand the technology
as well as they'd like to think and B
doesn't realize that almost all of them
are commoditized
and that the people that are actually
going to win are going to be far more
based on the operators that drive the
car than the car that they're building
and so I would say that people need to
be very thoughtful
during this next half decade because
there's a lot of new really substantial
Technologies but just because it's
happening doesn't mean it's going to
work out it's similar to why in the
height last year of nfts I started going
completely the other way and making
videos saying 99 of these things are
going to zero the macro of an nft is
right but the individual projects
weren't no different than sports cards
or just talking like sports cards or art
are good Investments the problem is for
the 7 to 50 people that in this town 80
years ago that were smart and bought
Jackson Pollock there was thousands of
other people that bought Jackson
schmalek
and lost a ton of money like yeah
Michael Jordan's rookie card is worth a
lot of money but 99 of athletes are not
99 of AI startups are going to fail
and so I think people need to be
thoughtful I didn't need to get more
specific I've literally had a friend
come to me 10 years ago we need to
invest in water it's the future of
course it is but it's it's water just
like is that's exactly right and but I
think you know like this is where we get
caught even when we're
seasoned and good we get excited you're
like oh I like this I like I know this
space is happening just have to be in
times like this especially and I'm sure
people have noticed this the speed in
which these companies are popping up is
extraordinary
like you know I look at something that
like AI creative is extremely
fascinating to me but the second like I
spend five minutes a year ago looking at
mid-journey there was like 20 other
competitors I didn't even know existed
and like by the way there's 20 popping
up a day right now
because the technology itself is
fascinating and the speed in which it
can matter so I just think people just
need to be thoughtful during this time
yeah
last two lightning round questions for
you uh you know you mentioned a little
bit again ahead of your skis or a little
bit of um you know a little bit of maybe
hubris that we all kind of see ourselves
in when we have some good Investments or
good whatever what's how do you view
luck I mean going back to the last
battle I just love your grit I love your
hustle are you like a Chance favors to
prepare a guy or how do you make your
own luck or is it something different
the way I look at luck is based on how
the person that's deploying the word is
weaponizing it
oh man that was good well well let's
talk it through like what do I think
about luck I was traded for wheat
I was born in the Soviet Union
the way I got to this country where
entrepreneurship is put on a pedestal
versus what happened to both my
grandfathers which was by being
entrepreneurs in Soviet Russia they
spent meaningful time in jail
so I get here and get to stand on fancy
stages and hang out with cool people and
my grandfather's my mom's dad spent 10
years in jail for selling like sausage
for tile
so what do I think about luck I think
it's [__] real like you know your mom
and dad had sex at the right moment
that's why you're even sitting here
can't anyone understand it's a variable
on the flip side
all my friends and acquaintances who sit
around and do nothing and watch cable
television news and make themselves
depressed 24 hours a day and produce
nothing and do nothing and then decide
to deploy luck on their friends or
contemporaries as a weapon to prove
something to themselves based on what
they're not doing I don't believe in
that version of luck so I think luck is
real but I think it depends on the
context
I think everyone here is lucky because a
million things happen for you to get
here including avoiding disease and so
many things like that just it's it's the
human Spirit but when people look at
anyone who actually works and says
they're lucky like LeBron was lucky the
way he was born you know how many hours
of work went into that finished product
and you know how many people were born
with that same capability so I think you
have to be careful in the context of how
you deploy it
that's really well said um thank you sir
what uh what is the last question what's
in the future for Gary are the Jets
still on the table are you going to make
another song with Snoop for anyone it
was a no check that out
um
the buying the Jets thing has been there
since third grade I want to continue to
try to pull it off it's a big part of my
journey but I think I really I started
to understand it in my late 30s early
40s which was like oh I love my craft
I've always loved being an entrepreneur
I always want to do business I guess
even at a young age I subconsciously
understood if I make a huge goal I'll
always be playing you know I think I
think I'm a counter puncher and what I
mean by that is I really don't know the
answer to that question I know that I
like being active as a business person
as a communicator I'm really in a small
group of people that
really the thing they love is also a
thing they ended up being good at so I'm
incredibly driven by gratitude
um you know I'm in the life cycle where
I'm like you know I want to be
thoughtful about like what makes me
happy and be more thoughtful about my
choices I think one of the things I
loved the last panel for the people in
here that are built on grit or come from
the dirt or I really love that statement
of like not being impressed that
happened to me I was an atrocious
student and it wasn't until my late 20s
early 30s that I'm like wait a minute
I can kill all these Harvard [__] you
know like like so I understood that you
know
um but I think one of one of the
downsides of being driven by grit and
like basically willing it to success is
maybe you're not as selective you know
like you know I'm I've built in a lot of
ways where I'm just like I'm doing
everything always at 100 I think you
know I want to be a little bit more
selective but the reality is I know that
I just want to keep
you know cultivating relationships
through the context of business that
leads to Great friendships still play my
game like I desperately want to die at
my desk and what I mean by that is like
I don't see like I don't know what to do
if I'm not like
being active like I don't understand
being 91 and like I don't want to fish
you know like like so so I I kind of
anticipate always doing but like
you know I just I just want to do stuff
and then I want to communicate about it
with the hope you know I'm incredibly
affected by the way I was parented and I
think when I analyze why do I put myself
so out there I realize that the words
that have predominantly my mom but a
good part of my dad the words that were
said to me formed how I rolled and I
think there's a lot of
intriguing advice both from parenting
and society that is just wildly not
practical to the truth of the situation
and so I'm motivated by doing stuff and
then communicating about it with the
hope that it impacts some people
positively
thank you so much I wish we could do
this for much longer but we appreciate
the attention thank you cheers
thank you thank you I learned about you
2015 on the brilliant idiots you say one
thing say dedicate 24 months to your
life to something your life will [__]
change I listened so it took me two
years to listen so now three years later
I started a media company we
bootstrapped to 17 full-time employees
um Channing has basically been my mentor
that's actually how I got invited to
this office it's amazing um so we're in
the gaming and Esports web 3 space and
we do a lot with the rocker I love it so
I just want to say hello send me an
email everything absolutely I'd love to
read it
thank you